Meier: So good afternoon,
everyone.
Thanks for coming along.
It's impressive to see
a packed room,
considering the quality of some
of the other sessions on,
but, uh, thanks
for coming along.
My name's Reto Meier.
I'm a developer advocate
for Android.
This is Michael Mahemoff.
He's a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
Today we're gonna have, uh,
a bit of a lighthearted debate,
looking at some of
the comparative differences
or advantages of developing
for mobile,
uh, using
either native libraries
or, uh, Web tools.
So before we get started,
um, it would be good for us
to have an idea of the audience,
see where we stand,
see which of us needs to be,
um, more convincing.
So with a show of hands,
how many of you
are doing Web-based
mobile development?
Ooh, I could be in trouble here.
Mahemoff: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
And the Android track? Nice.
Meier: And, uh, and how many of
you are, uh, android developers?
Outstanding.
Mahemoff: I think you're
on safe ground, too.
Meier: Yeah, I like this.
I like this.
All right, so we're both gonna
have to be really convincing.
That--that works.
That works pretty well.
So, uh, to get started,
I'm gonna introduce, uh,
or let Michael take us off
with some mobile tips
for Web development.
Mahemoff: Excellent.
So yes, uh, I'm making the case
for HTML5.
And of course,
when I talk about HTML5,
I'm not just referring
to the actual technical spec.
I'm talking about all the cool
Web technologies
we can use today--
uh, the open Web stack of HTML5
or HTML, CSS, and JavaScript,
and just this general trend
towards getting more know-how
about how we're doing things,
about faster browser run times,
and a whole community that's
evolving around these standards.
I want to frame this argument
around these three points,
so basically to say that HTML5
is a technology
that is here on the various
mobile platforms,
and then I want to tell you
that HTML5
is a very capable technology
as well,
because, you know,
I could say that--that, uh,
batteries are also available
on the various mobile platforms,
but they won't write
your killer apps.
Hopefully I can show you
that HTML5 will.
And finally, to talk
about some of the openness
and the fact that it's such
a widespread standard
as an advantage even over
a single native capability
or a single native platform.
So in summary,
to show you that HTML5
on the mobile devices rocks.
Firstly, the HTML5
is here on various mobiles.
And that--those are--
that's a bit of a summary
of some of the native platforms
you have to consider
when you're actually going
to reach people
on the different
mobile devices--
um, Linux systems,
Microsoft, Apple,
and all these
different versions.
Each of those things have got
their own programming language
to deal with.
And, you know, APIs and SDKs--
all of those things differ.
And you're gonna be having
to do a lot of relearning
or a lot of outsourcing
and a lot of work
if you want to actually target
all the different users
using these various
mobile devices.
So this is why you get
comments like this.
Uh, this one's
from the magazine industry.
They've got the sort of monthly
or weekly publications
coming out
and just struggling, you know?
It's costing them a lot
of time and money
to actually have to go through
and test, you know,
see what the content's like
on all these different
sort of, uh,
all these platforms
that they're putting
their apps out onto.
It starts to become compelling
to think about--
could we have one platform
to target all of these
different devices?
And HTML5 is here.
It's working on the mobiles
of today.
You couldn't imagine getting
a new phone
without having a browser.
And many of them do have
the latest features of HTML5.
You know, they're--many
of these phones using WebKit,
which is what we also use
on the desktop browsers
like Chrome.
They're also on the tablets
and even on other devices
as well, like TVs.
So they have browsers.
You can put your apps
in browsers.
Users click on links when they
see a tweet, for instance.
They'll click on a link,
and they'll--
that's what they will be opening
is the browser.
So you need to be there
on the mobile Web,
ready inside people's browsers.
And you can also embed your--
your apps,
or your Web view--
your Web apps
inside native apps as well.
There are techniques for this.
On the whole, uh,
the various operating systems
have said we don't want
the experience
of the user having to click
when they see a link,
and then it would open up
a separate browser app.
So the various native platforms
tend to provide a way
to actually embed a Web view
inside a native app.
And because of that,
Web advan--
Web developers have taken
advantage of that
to actually embed
their own Web app
inside the native app
that they've actually published.
So when you look at these
various programming languages,
you can also look at it
another way.
You can say, "well, let's just
deal with it as one platform,
"one programming language,
one set of APIs,
one set of design patterns
and conventions."
But is this for real?
Like, can you really try
to pull this off,
this idea of one platform
and one programming API
everywhere?
The reason it works
is--is not because of some magic
that says that you write
the same app everywhere,
it's because you do
actually have
the same technologies
everywhere,
but you still have to do
some customization
and make things fit the device
you're actually working with.
So right at the heart
of the Web
is all of these concepts
of dealing with multiple types
of devices.
The Web has these
three technologies--
HTML, JavaScript, and CSS,
you know that the--
they distinguish the content,
being the HTML--
that's something like
a content creator.
It might be a journalist--
that's the thing that they're
actually creating.
The JavaScript is the logic.
That's the thing
that programmers create
to actually control
the user computer interaction.
And the CSS is the kind of thing
designers work on.
And so because you get
that separation,
you can reuse a lot across
the different devices.
You can have almost the same,
or exactly the same HTML,
uh, the actual content.
You can reuse a lot
of the JavaScript.
And you can hopefully leverage
some of the CSS
and then customize it further.
We actually just showed that
in the previous talk,
uh, that I was involved with
earlier on today,
uh, just doing exactly that,
having very different
sort of user experiences
but the same markup
and most of the same JavaScript.
So this is something
that the Web's always had,
because the Web evolved
from a situation
where it wasn't tied
to any one particular device
or operating system.
The Web spread like wildfire
and continues to spread today
because it does run
on this huge variety
of different platforms
and operating systems.
Graceful degradation
is another aspect of that,
dealing with different types
of devices
and different levels of support.
So we talk about all these
latest and greatest
HTML5 features you've seen
like in the keynote today.
They're not all there
in all of the browsers.
But they don't--the app
just doesn't just go and explode
if--if your use--
if you're relying on something.
If you're doing it right
and doing it the way
Web developers
have always learned to do it,
you can fall back,
and the Web actually supports
that intrinsically.
So you've got this capability
to--to say--
the <canvas> tag--okay,
I don't have Canvas.
Then I'll just fall back nicely.
That's the content
that will be shown
instead of the <canvas> tag.
If the attribute
is not supported
because you're always--
HTML5 is always adding
new attributes
to do extra things,
like in this case to show--
to let you select
multiple files.
So in this case
that's not supported. Fine.
That will just get ignored.
There won't be an error,
it will just get ignored,
and you can just choose
a single file instead.
The style--the font's
not supported in this case.
So we can actually choose
the best possible font
we would want.
HTML5 lets us be very flexible
with our fonts.
We can actually--again, we can
fall back to a font that does.
So this is all the way--
the whole spirit
of the way the Web works.
Cascading Style Sheets
is another aspect of this.
So you can actually have
one style sheet,
and then that gets overridden
by other style sheets.
So you can say, well,
we've got our desktop app.
You can just publish
a normal app for the Web first,
see if it takes off, see
if it's interesting to people.
People can start using it
on the mobile already.
And then a couple
of years later,
you decide, well, now we can
start to customize a bit more
for the mobile
and have those rules
override the previous rules.
And then you can go
even further than that.
You can say, well,
we specifically care
about Android,
or we specifically care
about, um, the Motorola Xoom
or whatever.
You can go as far as you want,
and actually customize
as much detail,
but you don't always have to.
You can start
from a basic point,
get your app up and running,
and see if people like it,
and then tune it from there.
The Web's always had an idea
about fluid layouts as well.
So just by the nature of the way
the rendering works,
things tend to stretch
in a reasonable way.
And even more so,
people have got
well-established techniques now
for doing these kinds
of fluid designs
to deal with all sorts of
different screen resolutions.
Uh, we've got sort of like
the idea of--
of one cloud.
Um, this is a very big--
big idea in our industry.
And now what I'm saying to you
is with HTML5
you've got the ability to scale
horizontally very quickly,
because you're reusing
a lot of the logic.
You're--you're using
the same technologies
when you're jumping
onto these different types
of devices.
So you might actually still be
customizing a bit,
but you can do that
a lot quicker.
So that's sort of the view
from, like, HTML5
as a platform.
Um, on the mobiles,
HTML5 as a platform,
as far
as the functionality goes,
it's starting to get
these technologies
that will rival
the native technologies.
So we've got user interfaces--
let you see a lot of great
Canvas things,
like "Angry Birds" and so on.
But there's also things
beneath the surface as well,
the networking
and offline-type capabilities,
too, that we need.
And I'll show you some demos
of this in a moment,
but first I'll--I'll go through
some code examples,
just to show you
the kind of APIs
that will support
these sorts of things
we've always had
in the mobile browsers.
So we've got, for instance,
geolocation.
We can actually--
these are the kinds of things
that are actually in many cases
inspired by mobiles,
but they've come back
into the Web
so they can be used
in mobile Web apps
as well as on the desktop
and elsewhere.
Um, very straightforward API
for doing geolocation,
and as with all
of these sorts of APIs,
it's potentially sensitive.
So just like you would get
on an Android app--
you know,
you'll actually get asked
if you'll give it permission,
the Web has that concept
now, too.
You can do multi-touch,
so we do now have touch events,
and specifically we have
the ability
to do multi-touch
as part of the Web--
the standard ways
of handling events as well.
We get an array--
you can see there,
when there's a touch event,
you get an array
of all the touch objects.
We can do device orientation.
So there--that's now part
of the standard, too.
It works on Chrome
on the desktop
and some tablets as well.
Starting to get there.
And we've got standards
for speech recognition.
Uh, apologies,
that's a little small.
So that's input x-webkit-speech.
That works on Chrome
to do speech recognition.
And there are device APIs
as well
to actually just capture
different types of media.
And you can see that they're
actually building
on the existing standard.
So it's just a file input,
but if you give it
this extra attribute
of what it accepts,
the devices will be smart enough
to actually switch
into that form.
And on the output side
of things,
uh, we can do markup
and styling with semantic tags.
So we've actually got these
kind of much richer things--
much richer ways to explain
the content on our page.
And this is really useful,
right?
This means you create
your Web app like this,
you've already got your content.
You've handled your SEO.
You've got your--almost like
a kind of API built in,
because you've got this content
sitting there openly
on the internet.
You don't have to. You can
close it off if you want,
but the Web tends
to be open by default,
unless you get that kind
of sharing experience
just by structuring your apps
like this.
And--and then you can style it
really nicely, too.
So CSS 3 gives you
all these ways
of decorating that content
and getting the best
of both worlds.
You've got Canvas,
so for doing
even richer graphics--Canvas.
You've seen 3-D Canvas
or WebGL today as well.
Um, we can do these kinds
of graphics,
um, more and more inside
the various mobile devices.
And multimedia as well
is possible, too.
So we can actually do video
and audio now
as part of HTML5.
This is an example of a native
app that's on the iPad.
"Just One More"--they're using
Vimeo's HTML5 video API
to actually show videos
inside this native app.
I'm gonna switch gears now.
I'll show you a demo
of some of these things
I'm talking about here.
Let's see.
Get this guy on.
Whoa, which one are we on?
Two, four?
Meier: Two.
Mahemoff: Two, gotcha.
So this is geolocation.
So just to prove this works,
let's see how it goes.
So it's asking me if I want
to share my location.
So we've got the coordinates
showing up,
and it's doing a bit
of mashing up
to actually show the weather
and so on.
Multi-touch test--so this is
inside a browser.
As you can see here,
it'll actually detect all ten.
I'm gonna leave that one.
There's a more fun one.
So this is 3-D,
3-D transformations with CSS 3.
So that--you know,
this is decorated.
We can actually decorate
content this way.
And this is bitly.
So we'll jump here.
Uh, it's generating those graphs
in real time
inside the browser.
But the most fun one
is the one I've actually written
for this talk.
So you can see I've taken
a few photos
around the place here.
Inside the browser--
let's see if I can get
this working upside down here.
There we go.
And this app's running
offline as well.
So it--whoops.
Back up.
Yeah, so this app
is actually running offline,
so it's just stored,
so now I'm in the DOM.
So I'll go and put you guys
in the DOM as well,
in local storage.
Wait for it. I'm gonna
switch the camera around.
So say hi. Sorry, I can only
get the middle row here,
the middle aisle,
but go on, say, "hi, I/O."
That--whoops, wrong way.
[laughter]
Mahemoff: All right.
And it's kind of jumping around,
which way--whichever way I go.
I'll leave the--okay.
So now you guys
are in local storage as well.
So--so I can actually--
if I reload this...
Actually... I don't know.
I'll reload it
just to show you
that--that's
actually coming--
well, anyway,
it won't go offline,
but it will work.
You can try this later on.
If you try that URL--
html5photos.appspot.com,
you can see how that works.
You can try it on the tablets
you got yesterday,
'cause I've tested it.
It works on there.
It's just a basic
proof of concept.
And it also works
on the desktop,
um, where you can
actually use it
as a way of keeping
photos offline
just by using the file import
and pulling photos
from your hard drive.
Now let me jump back.
But it's more than just the user
interface side of things,
it's also about doing
these sorts of things
in, uh, you know--
the sort of back-end
functionality as well,
so things like networking.
The--where the Web
really took off
was a few years ago when we had
this concept of Ajax.
It was the recognition
that suddenly the user could be
working in the browser,
and at the same time you could
have all this communication
going on back to the server
that sent down that application.
For security reasons,
you couldn't actually go
to other domains.
A few hacks have come about
to make that possible,
but now we've actually got that
built into the standards
as well.
So we can start to do
really sophisticated mash-ups
by using cross-origin
or resource sharing
and going across
to other domains.
And we also have WebSocket
and some other technologies
as well
to do proper real-time
streaming.
So it's not just a case
of the browser making a request.
We can also do
a live communication channel
back and forth.
You can see,
Rumpetroll will work already
on some mobile devices.
Uh, offline--
so this app here,
it does work offline.
You can try it for yourselves.
Just visit it once
and then take it offline.
And try it
and then hit "reload."
You'll see it'll work.
It's using
the application cache--
very straightforward technology
where essentially you just need
to list your assets.
And some of you might have seen
the Chrome
Web store talk yesterday,
where people like
"The New York Times"
were mentioning that it's
not just about being offline.
It's also a massive
performance improvement.
So the same sort of situation
as a native app,
where you have your content--
you have your app
as well as your content
that are all stored
inside the device,
you can do the same thing
with the Web now.
You don't have to make it
like every time
you go and start this app,
it's gonna load the whole thing.
And offline storage is
another aspect of this as well.
So you can actually have,
you know--
storing not just
the application logic,
but also the actual content.
So that's showing you that HTML5
is here on the mobiles,
and it's also a very capable
technology.
But it's more than that.
It's also just some
intrinsic things
about the way the Web works.
And I think they're
quite compelling for developers.
It is based on standards,
So while it takes
a little bit longer
for those standards to evolve,
and it's kind of a messy
standards process,
ultimately what you end up with
is several implementations
of these standards,
and these implementations,
like you've seen--
with these massive performance
increases we've seen
from the likes of Chrome,
that it causes a lot
of competition
between the different browsers
to keep innovating,
and also to keep coming up
with new standards.
Like I've tried to show you
here today,
it's okay for a browser
to go ahead
and come up with a new feature
that might not yet be
on the other browsers,
because you have ways
to degrade,
and there is a standards process
for the other browsers
to adopt those standards, too.
And--and it's also the fact
that you're on the Web.
You've got that content
sitting on the Web,
so you've already got a lot
of your search, uh, problem
already solved
and the ability of making it
accessible as well
to things like screen readers.
The actual technology of the Web
is becoming more and more,
um, popular.
It's very much already
for a few years now--
it seems to be what people
like to think of
as a lingua franca,
a language that--
just by its privileged place
in the browser,
everyone has to know
some JavaScript
and some HTML5.
There are now huge communities
of Web developers
who consider it their first
and favorite language.
There are other people who
still prefer other languages,
but they still know
a lot of these technologies.
And we even have
server-side technologies
like Node now,
that let you write
the entire app on the server
and the browser in the same, uh,
set of core technologies
and the same programming
language.
So you can see why people
like this.
This is a quote
from "The Onion" here,
but it is actually serious,
I'm told.
Um, it is basically--
they're making the point
that they've got the iPad app,
and they're doing it in HTML5,
because they already know it.
They already have a Web site.
They have to have a Web site.
They have
to have things running
as apps on the Web.
So they're just leveraging
all of that existing skill
and--and resources.
And finally,
HTML5 is a very well-supported
technology now.
It's been around
for a long time.
And you've got some great
libraries that have evolved
since the whole Ajax revolution,
libraries like jQuery
that you hear a lot about.
Um, there's great
debugging tools.
There's Chrome Dev Tools
for instance,
that make life a lot easier
for developers.
And there's a whole community
as well.
So there's a lot of, uh--
it's very easy
to--to get on board
with HTML5
You just open up a text editor
and write something
and run--run it in your browser.
Everyone can do that.
And just to actually skill up
from there
is a lot easier
than it used to be.
And there's just this
huge community of blogs
and tutorials
and everything around it.
So I think
I will leave it there
and give it to Reto.
Meier: All right,
thanks very much, Mike.
[applause]
Mahemoff: Thank you.
Meier: He'll be back later,
but, uh, I'm sure he...
Mahemoff: Appreciated anyway.
Meier: appreciates the applause.
Um, so he's made
a good point, right?
Um, there's some really
interesting stuff there,
some really compelling reasons
why, you know,
building applications
for mobile phones on the Web
is a really good idea.
Uh, what really appeals to me
is this idea
that you have this
cross-functional approach,
that you have an app
you write once,
and it works across
all the smartphones,
or at least all the modern
smartphones
where you want your app
to be used.
So why would you risk--
why would you risk losing that?
You know, why build an app
which is only one platform?
Well, there's
100 million reasons,
in one instance,
why you might want to.
There's a lot of Android apps
out there.
And we want to try
and create something
that's optimized
for those users.
Before I get into the details,
I want to talk a little bit
about the terminology
we're using.
So we've thrown the word
"native" around
quite a lot already.
Um, if you're Android
developers,
often when we're talking
about native apps,
we talk about something
slightly different
from what we might be
considering.
So for today when we're
talking about native,
it's really anything built
specifically for
the Android platform.
'Cause there's actually a few
ways that you can do this.
It's not just about
writing things
for the Java virtual machine.
That is the most common way
of doing it.
So most of you guys,
if you're Android developers,
are probably writing things
using Java Syntax,
which is going to be running
on the Dalvik virtual machine.
And that's certainly the, uh,
the majority of apps.
We also have a number
of different alternatives.
And one of those is actually
what we call native development.
Um, so that's using
the native development kit.
And you can actually build apps
using C or C++.
And that takes you one level
further down.
So rather than running on top
of the virtual machine,
you're actually running
much closer
to the metal underneath that.
Uh, we also launched something
called Renderscript,
which is a way that you
can write even faster,
um, graphics code.
And that's how things
like the, uh,
Google Books
page turn animation works,
The YouTube dynamic gallery.
All of that stuff
is written in Renderscript,
uh, which is actually--
the coding language there
is a variation of C--C99
And we also have the ability
of using the Android
Scripting Layer
to be able to write things
in scripting languages,
things like Python, Perl,
those sorts of languages.
You can actually build apps
using those languages as well,
though they'll have to run on--
on top of an additional
interpreter.
So when I say, you know,
I want you to build native apps,
I can mean any of these things.
I don't really mind
how you do it,
but I do want you to focus
on Android specifically,
and on the hardware layer.
So what are the advantages?
Why--why are we wanting
to build native apps?
It's really because it gives you
a much richer experience.
You're able to build things
which have much broader access
to the underlying hardware.
And it's not just that.
You also have
a closer integration
to the system features.
You have this ability
to create apps
which are optimized
specifically for the hardware
that they're running on,
specifically for the systems
that they're running on
and with the other software
that's gonna be running
on those systems.
So it gives you the ability
to write something
that's not just an app,
which is running on a screen,
which could be running
on any hardware.
It lets you create something
which is optimized
for the things beyond
the screen size,
with the hardware
which it's running on as well.
So why--again, why develop?
So for me it's all about power.
It's the ability
to write something
that's faster, smoother,
more efficient,
and that was a key element
in one of the presentations
I gave yesterday
around how to build
great mobile apps for Android.
And it's all about trying
to make things
as smooth, as fast,
and efficient as possible.
The thing about mobiles
is that they are
resource-constrained devices.
They're getting
increasingly powerful.
They're great with tablets,
dual-core, all of these things.
But it is fundamentally
still a resource-constrained
device.
Manufacturers are gonna try
and make the devices smaller,
and they're gonna try and make
the batteries last longer.
And that's gonna come
as a priority
above making them run faster,
which means that every ounce
of efficiency
that you can pull
out of a device
to make your app work better
is going to be valuable.
And so when it comes to the idea
of building something natively
or building something
on the Web,
you--you're basically asking
the question
can you afford to lose
the additional efficiency
and power requirements
by sticking another layer
in between your app
and the device
that it's running on?
The thing is
all of that is true,
and even if the functionality
of HTML5
was exactly the same
as native,
then that--
that's already a reason
to think about building
native instead.
But there's a whole bunch
of additional functionality
which you can take advantage of,
which is why I really think
if--if you can't improve
on a Web app
using some of the native--
the Android SDK APIs,
then you're probably
just not trying hard enough.
And so that's a laugh
from the Android part--
part of the crowd.
I thank you for that.
But no, seriously, there is--
there are so many things
which you can do now
using the, uh,
the native APIs.
And it's--it's really
all about innovation.
So the--the great thing
about the Web
is that it's
standards-based, right?
The whole advantage
is that you write it once,
and you can optimize it
for a number of platforms,
but fundamentally
you can write it once
and run it all across the Web.
And that's fantastic.
The way that works is because
it's all standards-based.
And the problem with standards
is that they necessarily
have to trail innovation.
You can't--you can try
to set a standard
before a piece
of hardware exists.
It doesn't generally work
really well.
A much better approach
is to find out
what's happening.
What are people innovating with?
What are people using?
And then create standards
to be able to make that
more broadly available.
that's fantastic.
But what we're seeing is
a lot of the most popular apps,
a lot of the most
successful apps
are right at the leading edge
of that innovation trail.
And that goes both in terms
of hardware and software.
If you're looking
at hardware itself,
the rate at which
mobile hardware innovation
has been traveling
over the last few years
is phenomenal.
If you think--compare that
to Netbooks, notebooks,
any sort of desktop computer,
it's been pretty much
the same thing for decades.
Right? Once the joystick
fell out of favor,
it was screen, keyboard, mouse,
and then different ways
to, uh, to connect peripherals.
But fundamentally it was
the same user experience.
With mobiles
that's completely changed.
It's only a few years ago
when the first iPhone came out
that we started to have
multi-touch on mobile devices,
accelerometers for being able
to do game control.
And then, you know,
Android comes on the scene,
we get access
to the video APIs, compass.
Background apps start to appear.
And then every year
that's improved.
So next was Bluetooth,
multiple screen sizes.
Then last year we had
gyroscopes,
front-facing cameras.
And these things have really
revolutionized a lot of apps.
Think about some of the apps
which you use
which are only possible
because of these innovations.
And the leaders were the ones
which were able to get in there
and take advantage
of those new APIs
as soon as they were released,
without having to wait
for everyone else
to be able to, uh,
to do it as well.
This year we've seen barometers
on the Motorola Xoom.
I haven't seen anyone use that
very constructively yet,
but I am looking forward to it.
NFC--huge.
It's a staggering technology,
which is starting to roll out.
You can wait until every phone
has NFC,
or you can start building apps
which take advantage of it now
and be a market leader
for when everyone does
have, uh, NFC.
Tablets, USB accessories,
uh, Android@Home--
all of this great stuff
which we've seen launched
over the last couple days.
All of that is an opportunity
for you to create
something new,
something innovative,
um, to be at the real forefront
of that market.
What we're seeing these days
is the device manufacturers--
they're using hardware
as a way to differentiate.
And that's one of the advantages
of Android.
They all have the same
software platform,
so they need to build
cleverer hardware.
They need to come up
with new features.
So this is what we've seen over
the last three or four years.
Imagine what we're gonna see
in the future.
I think it's gonna continue
to innovate
and continue to grow.
We've seen exactly the same
thing on the software side.
Right? So along
with that hardware,
we've also seen great
innovations in mobile APIs.
And these are some examples
of some apps
which have really taken
advantage of this
and become market leaders,
whether it's Google Maps using
location-based services,
which we all totally take
for granted now, right?
We all know that our phones
know where we are.
Uh, you know,
this is just assumed
that every mobile device
can do this,
but it's actually
a relatively recent thing.
Uh, Shazam using audio input,
Goggles using video input
to do video recognition--
image recognition.
"Angry Birds"--touch screens.
The way games are played
has changed.
It has been totally
revolutionized by smartphones
with accelerometer input,
um, compasses, video,
all of these sorts of things.
So really what I'm saying
is leverage the hardware
that's available,
particularly when new platforms
are coming out.
So we've all been using
smartphones for a long time.
It's been, what, three years,
so it's pass now.
What we're looking at now
is tablets.
And all of you guys
have tablets,
so there's no excuse for not
getting into tablet development.
And--and it's more, right?
There's Google TV--that's
around the corner as well--
I mean literally
around the corner.
It's actually out.
Um, and we're seeing things--
we're seeing Android really,
you know,
populate a much broader
spectrum of devices,
whether it's cars
or, you know, whatever else.
We're seeing
this single platform
as a place where you can really
take advantage of the hardware.
We're gonna build the APIs to
make it easier for you to use.
And that's what
the Android accessories
development kit
is all about as well.
It's trying to give you
as developers access
to be able to program
for more things.
I mean, this is
really revolutionary.
We're now living
through a time
when we're making it possible
to write code
which runs specifically on
different hardware platforms.
It wasn't that long ago
that it was very difficult
to actually get a piece
of software you wrote
to run on an actual phone that
someone would go out and buy.
And now that's something
that you can do right now.
If you get bored during one
of the presentations,
you can write an app,
launch it on Market,
and it'll be there.
And what we're seeing
is that this is now
propagating across
a whole variety of hardware.
So one of the key messages
I want to take away from you--
or give you guys
to take away from this
is think about
the actual hardware
that your software
is running on.
If you're building something
for Google TV,
you should think about the APIs
that are specific to that.
How can you integrate
TV guide information
or, you know, whatever else
makes sense for that hardware?
And it's the same with tablets.
It's the same with smartphones.
And that--and that's what
native gives you
is the ability to start
using that hardware
as soon as it's available,
rather than having to wait
until it becomes ubiquitous.
And so this is some--
some of the stuff
which is available,
uh, right now
for native development.
Um, so obviously you can develop
for smartphones,
tablets, and TVs.
Audio input is ubiquitous.
Video input from front-
and rear-facing cameras
is all there today.
Uh, 10-finger multi-touch input,
um, which I will grant you,
Mike, is now also available
on, uh,
on many mobile platforms for
Web-based development as well.
And things like
a generic sensor API,
so that as new hardware sensors
get added
to, uh, pieces of hardware,
you're able to integrate that
into your applications
really easily.
And that's where we're seeing
things like orientation,
accelerometers, barometers,
a variety of new hardware.
I think there's gonna be a lot
of growth in that area as well.
One of the key things as well,
which isn't as common,
is this ability to get
right to the low levels.
So having access
to the telephony, Bluetooth,
SIP stacks, USB--
all of these things make it--
make it possible
for you to create apps
which fundamentally interact
with hardware.
And in fact, it goes
that one step further,
because your native apps
aren't just something
which sits in a sandbox,
in an application sandbox,
or within the browser.
They become part of
the ecosystem on the device.
So that means
that you can do things.
You can actually work
with the system.
You can listen
for system events.
So if you want to build an app
which is going to, uh,
listen for incoming calls,
do a reverse number lookup,
and display who the caller is,
you can do that.
You can register an intent
to listen for incoming calls.
You can do the same thing
with other apps.
So if you want to have an app
where you want to display
a location,
you're able to make a call,
again using
the intent framework,
to say have something display
this on a map.
And if Google Maps is installed,
it'll do that for you.
You can do the same thing
in reverse.
So if you have an app that can,
uh, book hotels,
and you say, "well, look,
any app which wants
"to be able to do this,
just send me
the name of the hotel,
and I will book it for you."
So it's a way that you can have
all of these apps
interacting with each other,
as well as interacting
with the citizen--
uh, with the system itself,
because they are
all first-class citizens,
which means you can replace
any of the apps
on the device as well.
If you think you can build
a better home screen,
build it, launch it,
put it in Market,
and people will be able
to use it--
same with dialers,
same with contact managers.
Anything which is on the phone
you're able to create
an alternative for.
Another thing which I really
like about native apps
is that they can be
truly background.
And obviously the most--
the most common use case
for this is a concurrent app,
like, have a music player
in the background,
and then you can continue
browsing at the same time.
But it's really more than that.
Native apps let you be able
to have much fresher data
by being able
to continue to update
in the background,
even if the app isn't running.
So you don't have
the associated battery drain
of having something
which constantly runs.
You can set an alarm
and say when connectivity
returns, do this.
Or if, uh, if an incoming call
comes in,
that's when I want my app
to be started up
and to be active.
And for all other times
it can be completely stopped.
It can be not running at all.
You can also do things
like a server-side push...
so Cloud to Device Messaging
lets you transmit a message
from a server to your app
to say
you have new information,
so start up
and download something
or notify the user of something.
You can actually do
the same thing on the device.
Uh, so again, you can have these
recurring background alarms,
so your device--your app
can be completely off.
In fact, the device
can be on standby.
And you can say, look,
every hour,
I want you to wake up, pull down
the latest news headlines
or tweets
or whatever it is you want.
And then as soon as the app
gets launched,
It's able to have that fresh,
up-to-date data.
And the advantage here
is twofold.
Not only do you get
fresher data
without having to do
an exclusive reset.
but you also save
on battery life,
because your app doesn't need
to be constantly running
in the background in order
to get those updates.
Full offline support,
I mean, this is something
which again is coming to HTML,
but it's something
which is really rich
on the native platform.
So not only can you have,
you know, your app data cached,
you can actually download
the entire contents,
store them on the device,
and have them available
for things like search.
I use GMAIL every morning
on my way into work.
I triage my e-mail--
constructive use of my time.
The thing is I commute to work
via the London Underground,
which means I have
no internet connection
for most of that journey,
but it doesn't matter.
I open up GMAIL.
I read all of my messages.
Archive, reply to--
put it in my pocket.
And then as I walk
to the office,
it gets a 3G connection,
and everything is synced.
By the time I sit at my desk,
everything is up to date.
And it's that rich
offline support
without ever really needing
to be online at all,
uh, which creates a really great
user experience.
One of the other things--
and this is something
which I really like
about Android specifically--
is the fact that your apps
become more than just, uh,
an icon in the launcher.
You can create
home screen widgets,
live wallpapers.
Uh, you can have notifications
which get triggered to--
to tell you of things like, uh,
you know, incoming e-mail
or instant messages.
And because all apps are created
equal on the platform,
you can do anything which any
of the native apps can do.
And so this is
a really great way
of being able to make
your content much more engaging.
So someone doesn't
have to remember
to navigate to your site
or look up a bookmark
or even start your app
in the launcher.
By having widgets,
notifications,
you're able to pull
more traffic,
more engagement,
more users into your app.
'Cause that's ultimately
what you want
is for people to use
your app more.
Downloading it is really
only the first step.
So this is a little summary
of all of the things
that you can do
using native APIs
across all
of the Android devices.
And there are additional things,
which limit it
to some of the newer versions,
but this is pretty
fundamentally everything
that is there.
So, uh, I'm gonna
hand back over to Mike.
Mahemoff: Okay, so I just wanted
to really summarize
our two arguments,
and then we'll shift gears
a little bit
towards making this practical.
So to sum up,
really what I'm saying here
is that HTML5 is a technology
that's here now
on the mobile devices
as well as any other--
many other types of hardware.
It's a capable platform as well,
so it's got these events,
UI capabilities I've shown you,
and beyond that.
And it's an open technology.
It's something that many people
in your organizations
probably already know.
And you have to have
Web apps anyway.
People will use the browser.
So it's got all those benefits.
On the other side of things,
Reto's pointed out
native apps tend to be
more integrated,
with the--the deeper
hardware integration
that tends to stay a step ahead,
um, as well as the fact that
you've got the user experience
that's, like, built into
that native look and feel
for each of the platforms.
Um, so really the next point
really is just to say,
like, what can we actually do
about these things?
Meier: How many of you guys
were hoping
that we would give you
one answer
so you would be able
to come out knowing?
[laughter]
Meier: Yeah, a few of you?
It's--it's really not that
straightforward, right?
It's not as easy
as which should I do?
If--if it was that easy,
then Google would just do one.
But we don't.
We do both.
And fundamentally,
that's the answer, right?
You--you can't just be focusing
on one thing.
It's--it's pretty clear
at this point
that the Web is the future,
so you cannot ignore this
as a platform.
And if you want real reach,
then building a mobile app,
um, which is Web-based,
is--is kind of a no-brainer.
You can build one app,
and it's gonna run
all across all of these devices.
And for a lot of content,
that's gonna make perfect sense.
You should be building something
which everyone can use.
But at the same time,
there's all these native APIs,
all of these native advantages
which can let you
build something really great.
So fundamentally,
I guess what we're saying
is maybe build a Web app
for everyone,
and if you've already got
a Web site,
then it kind of
should already be
a mobile-optimized
Web site as well.
That's increasingly how people
are trying to access Web content
is on mobile browsers.
So that's kind of a gimme.
Beyond that you want
to then create
an optimized version
using those native APIs
to build something better.
One of the ways you can do this
while leveraging the work
you've already done
is by using WebViews.
Most of the smartphone platforms
have something equivalent
to a WebView,
but I'm gonna talk
about Android specifically.
But this is a way that you can
embed Web content
into your native applications.
It--it's kind of an obvious
thing to do here.
If you've got content which
has already being formatted,
looks beautiful,
you've got your UX people
building stuff in HTML,
why not use that
to display the content
within your applications?
What you do then is that becomes
the mainstay of your app,
and then everything else
becomes chrome.
So you then--you know,
all of the action bars,
all of interaction
with accelerometers,
with the native hardware--
you can do all of that stuff,
but then just display
the content
specifically using a WebView.
And in fact, if you've been
using the Google I/O app
throughout the conference,
you've already been using an app
which does exactly this.
So all of the, uh,
the maps are actually done
not using a MapView,
but by using a WebView,
which using the Google Maps API.
And you can see we've got
the real-time stream of tweets,
I think.
Um, and that also is going
to be just a WebView,
um, which has a particular
amount of content put into it.
Everything else
is purely native.
So all of the action bar stuff,
all of the things
which are optimized
for tablets or smartphones
is all done natively.
But we have this ability
to just wrap the content,
um, for specific parts
of the app
using a WebView.
Mahemoff: And I just want
to finish off
with just a few tips
on just HTML5
and JavaScript in general
when you're dealing
with mobile devices
and going across
the various platforms.
Firstly, there are
libraries available.
I already mentioned
that you've got these libraries
that are now very powerful
and very widely used,
like jQuery,
that are just used
for general Web applications.
Those things also work.
They work quite nicely
in most cases
on the mobile devices as well.
and at the same time,
there are more and more
mobile-specific HTML5
frameworks and libraries
that you can hook into.
So there are things like--
um, we've got Sencha Touch here.
This is an example of an app
they've created
that works
right across the board,
showing a conference schedule.
SproutCore--it's a touch app.
You can see the same kind of app
running in the Chrome
Web store as well.
So it's that experience,
or that--that philosophy
of writing the same app.
In the case of the mobile
or the tablets,
you can swipe
and just go across.
Otherwise you use the mouse
on the desktop.
Um, it's an NPR app, actually.
And--and jQuery mobile
is kind of the new kid
on the block here
and--and already very popular,
because it's based--
or it's the similar sort
of concept as jQuery
with the same team.
Um, it's--
it's actually very, um,
sort of more of
a micro kernel approach,
um, and it's got
the ability to theme,
so you can cover
the different devices,
and a very permissive license
as well,
being MIT based.
Think about
progressive enhancement,
the idea that you have
your raw, basic Web site,
uh, a traditional Web site,
just some markup,
again, something we showed
in the previous session
on--on mobile development
for the Web
is--you know,
this actually does work.
We showed this working
in your basic browsers
like Opera Mini.
And many people do
actually still access the Web
from very traditional, uh,
from very traditional devices,
you know, that have very basic
Web capabilities
on the mobiles.
And if you do your app right,
you can actually get it working
for those as well.
And then you go ahead
and you enhance it,
so you're actually--
in this case we're basically
"hijacking" these links
to actually say
if we do have JavaScript here,
we're gonna go further,
and we're gonna
actually not go ahead
and click to reload the page.
Instead we're gonna do
something dynamic.
We can do fallbacks.
So I already showed you,
you can do fallback with
something like <canvas>
or any other tag.
If it doesn't exist,
the--the browser
or the HTML5 runtime,
it will still process it.
And we can do that sort of thing
with video, too.
We can fall back from,
you know, one format
to another format
to Flash
to just downloading.
We can do feature detection--
um, very important thing
nowadays--
based on the premise
that you can't try to detect
every sort of different device.
It's just not practical.
And even if you could,
you wouldn't want
to create separate apps
for all these different devices.
So rather than having
this whole, uh,
combinatorial explosion
of--of apps
you have to deal with,
just put a little bit
of intelligence
into your app
to make some decisions
as the app is actually running
about what to do
and then perhaps download
some extra content
or some extra type
of application logic,
depending on what are
the capabilities
of the current device?
Like I said before,
HTML5 is not perfect.
It's not a magic bullet.
You still have to do some
difference of logic and so on
to reach all these
different devices.
But the benefit you get
is a vast amount of reuse.
There's library support
for this sort of thing, too.
So we've got a library
called Modernizr
that's becoming
extremely popular,
um, which actually does
the detection for you.
On a previous slide, I showed
the kind of low-level detection
you can do,
sort of doing things
like creating something
and seeing if it
actually was created
or setting an attribute
and seeing--
reading it back to see
if the browser
actually recognized it.
You don't really have to do
those low-level things anymore
for feature detection,
because there are libraries
like Modernizr
that do it for you.
There's also a slightly
higher-level layer on Modernizr
that will actually--
uh, it doesn't have
to be Modernizr,
but it--it's basically, uh,
around those kind of use cases
for people who are using
Modernizr, called YepNope.
And basically just--
basically it says, you know,
if you've got this feature,
we're gonna download
an extra layer
of JavaScript and CSS.
If not, we'll use
something else.
Polyfills is the idea
that you don't necessarily
have to fall back.
I've already talked
about graceful degradation.
But what if you could actually
just fake it, right?
And actually say we don't have
this particular feature.
We might not have SVG
in a browser like IE 6
for instance,
So we'll just fake it.
We'll fake it
with something else.
Um, so in this case we can say
there's a library called canvg,
um, which will actually fake SVG
using Canvas
for things that have Canvas
but not SVG.
Um, storage--so I've already
shown you a little bit
about local storage to make
your apps work offline.
Really old browsers,
uh, don't have
even the basic
local storage support.
So for those browsers,
you can resort
to everyone's friend,
the old cookie,
and store a very minimum--
minimal amount of data,
but you can still do something
useful with that,
and likewise geolocation
and so on.
And the point about these is
you can use them yourself,
so you can talk
to that more modern API.
And eventually when
those devices
and browsers become deprecated,
you can just switch off the--
any kind of checking.
But also for
third-party libraries,
these are really powerful,
because the third-party
libraries
might be taking advantage
of those newer features.
And you can sort of jump in.
JavaScript's
a very dynamic language
that lets you do these things
like what's called
"monkey-patching"
or "hijacking."
So you can sort of
intercept things
and say, actually, no,
the object you're talking to--
do this instead.
Use this object.
And finally, I wanted
to share with you--
I spoke to Roman, who actually
created the I/O app
that you have seen--
just the sort of techniques
that you can use
and he's using there
to actually communicate
back and forth
between the native components
of Android
and--and the HTML5 components.
So if you are creating one
of those sorts of hybrid apps
that Reto was advocating
a moment ago,
you can go in both directions
with Android.
You can basically have
a native part,
um, talk to
the--the JavaScript part,
basically making calls
using that loadURL command.
So, um, if you've got a WebView,
instead of actually loadURL
opening up a new Web site,
as you'd expect,
you can just pass it JavaScript
commands the same way.
Some of you might know
you can write those kinds
of JavaScript commands
on--on the actual browser,
like the way bookmarklets work.
And in the opposite direction,
HTML5 can actually talk
to the native components,
using this pretty cool method
that's addJavaScriptInterface.
So it lets you kind of,
uh, send in
a native component
into the JavaScript app,
and you basically provide
an interface for that.
That gives you full
communication between the two
and lets you writes--
write one of those hybrid apps.
I think that's about all.
We've got some resources there
to help you with.
And I think that's it.
I think we can take
questions now, yeah.
Great, thank you.
Meier: Thanks.
[applause]
man: Um, one of the technologies
that you didn't talk about,
and they also have a--
sort of a similar message
is, um, Adobe Flex and AIR,
uh, because that's available
on Android, on Blackberry,
PlayBook,
and also there is a way
to get it onto iOS.
Um, what would you suggest
the strategy--
like, Adobe AIR versus HTML5...
Mahemoff: Okay.
man: versus native?
Mahemoff: Yeah, I think
it's an interesting
sort of third situation
with, uh,
the Flash and AIR and so on.
Um, I guess the way
I see Flash--
people always ask me
about Flash.
Um, I think it's been
a good technology on the Web
for actually going, uh,
a step ahead,
like the same sort of way
Reto's talked
about native technologies
going a step ahead.
I think Flash
has always done that.
It's now gonna be a challenge
to see if it can
keep on going in that direction.
I think the Web
has some obvious advantages.
Um, the fact that people
do just have to have
normal Web sites
as an open technology
without any one
particular vendor
controlling its destiny,
if you like,
so I think that's where
the challenge
for that whole set
of technologies is,
like to keep staying
ahead of the game.
So you can have those kind
of native technologies,
um, but actually go across
the different devices.
Meier: Yeah, I think
that's the big challenge
for the Adobe stuff,
or really anything other
than sort of Web or native,
which are the two extremes,
is not getting stuck with
the negatives of both worlds.
You know, it doesn't work
on everything,
and it doesn't have a full range
of native support.
I think that's where
the challenge is gonna be.
Mahemoff: And there's also--
in some respects,
there's been better tooling,
traditionally,
for Flash as well.
So that's where the advantage
over the Web has been,
but now there's starting to be
a lot more tools for--
and actually not just
those sort of libraries
I've talked about,
but people are
just starting to write
sort of animation toolkits
and so on as well. Yeah.
man: Thank you.
man: Uh, yeah,
if you're developing
one of these hybrid apps,
uh, you've talked about
the JavaScript bridging,
is there also a way
where you can manipulate
or take over the cache
or the loading of subresources
within the WebView?
You can do that on iPhone.
Is there an analogous way
to do that on Android?
Meier: Uh, I'm not sure.
It's not an area which
I've looked at too closely.
I believe that you have
pretty much
full control over what happens
within a WebView,
but, um, don't take
my word for it.
I think they're still doing
Android office hours upstairs.
It'd be a good question
to ask someone there
from the browser team,
if you can find one.
man: Is there a particular
person you'd recommend?
Meier: I'm not sure
who's around, so no.
man: Okay. Thanks.
Meier: No problem.
man: The, um,
tabbed view you had
that included the HTML5 photos,
was there a URL
for that whole thing?
Mahemoff: Uh, I haven't got
a URL for the whole thing.
Um, I can put it on Twitter,
I guess, afterwards,
after this talk...
[speaking indistinctly]
man: Okay, but there was
no helper app to get that photo?
It was just looking
for a file...
[voices overlapping]
Mahemoff: Sorry, the URL
specifically for the photo app--
man: Well, that was
html5photos.appspot.
Mahemoff: Yeah.
man: And my battery died.
Excuse me. Um, but that thing
will trigger the camera
without a helper app?
Mahemoff: Uh, trigger
the camera is--
oh, well, that's just
on the slides,
so I've got the--
there's no URL.
I mean, it's just
"input type=file"--
man: Right, but you hit
the button. You got a photo.
Mahemoff: Yeah, that's just
a special kind of input type.
man: Okay.
Mahemoff: So I've done
"input type=file"
with a special except.
You'll see that on the slides
when they come out.
It's just a single line,
basically.
And then I'm using,
uh, Reader,
so you can actually--
there's also file APIs,
basically--
This is on HTML5 Rocks,
actually,
how you can actually
manipulate--
man: Oh, it is all there, okay.
Mahemoff: Yeah, once you've
got the file, you use
file input with that except
to actually put the file
in that--that element.
and you can then read it
using FileReader API.
man: Okay, thank you.
Mahemoff: Okay.
woman: Hi, uh, first of all,
awesome talk.
I actually was gonna
ask a question
based on the fact
that I'm sure you actually get
more of this input than I do.
So I didn't see this
on your list,
but do you think security
and transparency
is actually a factor?
So what I mean is, like,
when I look at an HTML5 app,
I can pretty much kind of look
at the HTML source.
I can figure out the JavaScript.
I can figure out
what's happening
behind the scenes.
And I can use user scripts.
I can use extensions.
I can kind of manipulate stuff
in there.
Native apps don't let you
do that.
And you know, even back
in the JTime days,
you wanted to kind of
do things to hide stuff
from your competitors.
So are you seeing developers
see that as one of the reasons
for picking one over the other?
Just curious.
Meier: Uh, well,
from the native side,
it's not something
that I've come across.
I mean, certainly
there's certain industries,
particularly around banking,
but to be honest,
they are very comfortable
with the way things work
on the Web now.
The advantage of the Web--it's
been around for a long time.
And there's some
really great security things
built into it,
and there's a certain level
of comfort.
Um, so as far as obscurity goes,
I haven't seen anyone
develop a native app
in order to make their code
more obscure.
Um, but I would imagine
that from a user point of view,
I guess, turning that round.
So a lot of the banks
are more comfortable
with a Web app,
because they are--
they understand
the security model.
They know that the users
understand the security model.
Um, so for users, yes.
Developers, probably less.
Mahemoff: And yeah--
one the Web side of things,
it's a little bit different.
We've seen this at the Chrome
Web store, for instance.
People tend to be concerned
about two things.
One is the application,
so people actually potentially
stealing the application
because it's open.
And the other is
the content, right,
so actually, uh,
digital rights management
and people actually being able
to lift movies and music
that those are actually serving.
Um, there's a couple of things
to say about that.
Firstly, there was
a really good comment yesterday
in the Web store panel
by the chap
from "New York Times"
who just made a point
that people who tend
to be really good,
the people that you have
to worry about as competitors,
don't tend to be the kind
of people who would
actually consider
doing that anyway.
Um, but beyond that, it's--
I think the way I like to see it
is that these technologies are--
have sort of a standard default
that you can vary.
So the Web tends to be
open by default,
but if you want, you can apply
obfuscation and so on
to--to close it off.
And likewise, uh,
native technologies
tend to be closed by default.
They're sort of binary.
But if you want, you can
always put the source up on...
woman: Yeah.
Mahemoff: you know,
on a repository or something.
So it kind of works both ways.
And it's really down
to the developers to...
woman: Thank you.
Mahemoff: My pleasure.
Meier: Yeah.
man: Right.
So I have two or three comments.
The first one is
you talked about, um,
I guess, on this side,
uh, about--
sorry--
the fact that, you know,
one of the advantages
of native is--is, you know,
less stress on the power.
And you didn't address this
on your HTML5.
I think that's a huge,
important thing,
because power is so critical.
Um, the other thing is--
and I guess
I'll just summarize it
by this--
is why--why not talk--
why not tinker just, like,
GWT instead?
Which is, you know,
write it for Android
and then compile it
for HTML5.
You know, and I'm sure there's
gonna be cases
where you're talking advantage
of the hardware,
and that compilation
wouldn't work.
But at least a lot
of the skunk work
that you would do in HTML5
can be done for you
by the compiler.
Mahemoff: I don't understand
how you can write it in Android
and then compile it in HTML5.
man: You write it in Java--
like, right now,
if you write it in GWT,
you can compile it
and it works--
Mahemoff: Oh, okay, using GWT.
man: Yeah, so now you do
an Android version of that.
Mahemoff: Yeah.
And that's--that's
the "Angry Birds" strategy
that's working in GWT,
so there is a possibility there.
Meier: Yeah, absolutely.
I think part of--
if I understand your question
or comment correctly--
I think one of the risks
if you're using
something like GWT,
it's the same sort of issue
that you may have
with something
like the Adobe solutions,
which is you build something
which is generic.
Then you may as well build it
using Web technologies.
And certainly GWT is a great way
to build Web technologies,
but I don't think that we
would get to a scenario
where we would want that
to output Android code.
man: No, I'm saying
the other way around.
Meier: The other way around.
man: No, you write...
Meier: Write Android code.
man: just in Android,
and then you tweak the compiler,
the Java compiler,
so that it generates HTML5.
Meier: HTML5. Okay.
So again, it's--
man: Because you have
the code already.
[voices overlapping]
Mahemoff: It can work.
It's another strategy, depending
on where you come from.
I actually had a partner
who did this
who actually--
with the Chrome Web store.
They already had an Android app,
and they were able
to really quickly--
actually, I was really surprised
about how quickly
they could use GWT
to actually turn it
into a very capable Web app.
So it is definitely a strategy,
if you've already got
the code base
and all the understanding
about how to do that, yeah.
man: What about
the power thing for--
Mahemoff: Yeah, it's a good
question, actually,
'cause Reto was talking
about this.
Um, Chrome now actually has
the concept
of background apps.
And it is just Chrome
at this stage,
but a lot of the things
that Chrome introduces
are intended to eventually
become standards.
And so--and it does actually
have this concept
that you'll see--
"New York Times"
is one, uh, company.
There's quite a few
that are starting to use it.
Um, so it can actually run
in the background.
Um, and actually, it kinda goes
against your point, too,
because it's actually using
more battery
while it's in the background.
Um, so, yeah, I mean, it's--
I don't know--why would you say
that it's using more battery?
man: Well, I mean,
I know iOS quite well,
and I can tell you
that iOS you get events,
and you have to put
your app to sleep.
Mahemoff: Right. I see.
man: And I think in Android
you have similar events.
I'm exploring them now.
So you--you essentially
are participating
as part of the platform...
Mahemoff: Yeah.
man: which is trying
as hard as it can
to, you know,
maximize battery life.
Mahemoff: So that's in contrast
to keeping a Web app running...
man: Yeah, that's right.
Mahemoff: the whole time.
And that's where
the background apps do help,
because with Chrome
you've got the ability
to launch these
background windows,
which are invisible windows
that can just wake up.
You know, we'll just run a timer
and just wake up every hour
or whatever and just do a poll.
So it's just starting
very early to get there
as far as the standards go.
Meier: I think what we're
gonna find
is that one of the advantages
behind Android
is that it's ultra optimized
for mobile--
like least power,
most efficient, et cetera.
The reality is--
is that the Web browsers
which are running
on these platforms
are gonna have exactly
those same things.
So Chrome originally was not
designed as a mobile browser.
That wasn't the focus.
The focus was around
all these other cool things,
which everyone uses
and wants to be able to do
in the most efficient way.
As we see things now,
more developers creating
browsers for these platforms,
that's gonna have to be
their focus as well.
And so there'll be solutions
to things
like the background stuff,
but also, um,
also just more efficiency,
generally speaking.
Mahemoff: Yeah.
man: So my question's
around if you do the HTML5 apps
or take a Chrome Web app
out of the Web store,
can you put it
in the Marketplace, too--
Android Marketplace?
Mahemoff: You can
using some technologies.
So there's ways, actually--
ways of actually
compiling it down
with some frameworks,
but there's also ways
of actually doing it yourself,
like what Reto was suggesting,
the kind of thing that the I/O--
man: So hybrid--hybrid apps,
you can--
then you can put
it in Marketplace.
Mahemoff: Yeah, and there are--
there are also frameworks,
and there are ways
of actually not just taking
the kind of approach
we've done here,
but actually compiling it.
So there are starting to be
some technologies
that people are doing
to actually take, um,
like, something that talks
to Canvas on the desktop,
and then it will go to OpenGL
on--inside an Android.
man: And then that would qualify
to be in Marketplace, too.
Okay.
Mahemoff: Well, you still
have to wrap it
as a native app, but yeah.
man: My question is related
to this one.
Uh, the way
that Chrome Web store
connects apps to users,
which are pure Web apps,
uh, doesn't it make sense
to have a similar store
that connects mobile Web apps
to the users
where people can discover
mobile Web apps
in some kind of a store?
Meier: Yeah,
that would make sense.
Um, I think the question
of how you put, um,
Chrome apps designed for mobile,
and make them more discoverable,
uh, on mobile devices
or Android devices...
man: And don't have
to wrap it up
just so that they can be
discovered,
so they can be first-class
citizens on their own,
being mobile Web apps.
Meier: So I'm not sure
internally
of what the plans are--
two separate teams.
So I have no idea.
Personally, my preference
would be to see search become
the way that you discover it,
so that you have search,
which is much better
at discovering
both native Android APKs
and Web-based apps as well,
rather than sort of having
different markets
or indeed any market.
But I have no idea
what the actual plans are.
man: All right, thanks.
Meier: Last question.
man: Uh, this is really more
of a comment
than anything else.
I guess one thing is that,
"A," if you guys are building
kind of a hybrid app
in this case,
you should probably
remind people
that the actual rendering engine
is not the same as what
they would have
in a browser or whatnot,
like for instance,
what the gentleman said there
about iOS--you know, the--
people are very surprised
when they get a UI WebView
and it doesn't have, like,
JIT compilation
on like mobile Safari
or something like that.
Um, two, for the, uh,
HTML5 portion of it,
remember, too, that the network
is the most expensive thing
when dealing with mobile,
less so than
the power consumption
and all that other stuff,
so if you're dealing
with lots of, you know--
I know that Android 2.0 and 2.1
supports HTML5 Web Workers,
and 2.2 and 2.3 do not anymore.
Thanks.
[laughter]
Meier: You're welcome.
man: Um, if you're doing that,
you're, like, you know,
pulling up a couple threads
in the background and spitting
off extra resources--
that's very expensive.
Um, and then three,
your solution
doesn't always work
in certain situations,
um, it's appeared
in an HTML5 Web app,
because, say, you're European,
and you use somebody
like Vodafone
or, um, you know,
Orange or something like that,
that use things like
content transformers actually
at, uh, the--
in the network operator level.
Your app is just toast.
And yours actually works.
Meier: It's definitely, uh,
there's definitely
no easy solutions.
And I guess that's
an important takeaway
is that you really need to look
at your market,
look at the devices,
and look at the technology,
so you can figure out something
that works best
for the what you're
trying to create.
man: Yeah. And, like,
I guess what the gentlemen
was saying before about GWT--
it was that it would great
to be able to take GWT itself,
have it export out HTML5.
Um, it does a little bit
of the exploratory
on the device,
sends it back to the server,
and actually optimizes
for that device,
so that you wouldn't have
to have that back-and-forth
that you would with Modernizr
or those other tricks
that you introduced.
Meier: All right then.
Mahemoff: Good points.
Thank you.
Meier: All right.
Thanks very much, everyone.
[applause]